In a recent stream I raised the question
How many of you haven't played demon souls?
And after a quick Twitter poll, I confirmed that 60% of my audience hasn't played.
This incredible music from the demon souls soundtrack
accurately represents my sadness at that fact because
my audience is entirely made up of salsa cuter born fans and as sucky born Souls fans know
it's difficult to play just one of these blood sucky souls games and
not touch the others.
To many of us demon souls is the game that started it all,
but as from software continues iterating on its success
New players are entering the series at later and later points
And as new sequels are created demon souls is being forgotten
Locked not only behind playstation exclusivity, but also
exclusivity in an older console generation the PlayStation 3 which is exactly why it deserves a
Remaster more than Dark Souls ever did to be honest
This was the first Souls game they ever made and it could really do with some quality of life changes not to mention
updated frame rates and textures since this is also a game that never got a PC release and
Let's be honest it never will so there's no way of experiencing these textures in higher resolution
nor frame rates at a stable 60 the closest you can get is emulation and
Ps3 emulation has come a really long way in recent years. It's come so far
In fact that I bet you didn't even realize this but the footage that you're seeing is from the emulated version
If you don't own a ps3, this is an option
But please if you do end up going down this route purchase the game as well. It's 25 bucks
Even if you don't have a ps3
Just grab a physical version in store or a digital version from Sony's website. It's the right thing to do
Demon Souls takes place in the age of the second scourge
The land of boletaria is enveloped by fog and demons have taken over
They're enriching their own Souls with the souls of humans many warriors venture into the fog to figure out what's going on
But only one makes it out and his royal knight named valor facts
Fala facts tells of king allant who in his lust for power
awakened an elder being called the old one the old one back into the fog the demons and it also
Unlocked the mystical soul arts, which is a tool that you may choose to use though
You do risk becoming one of the demons that you've set out to destroy
This isn't the first time the scourge has happened
It is called the second scourge after all and if someone doesn't enter the fog and defeat the demons
It might be the last scourge
I have a short series of Demon Souls videos if you want to learn more and I really should make more
Because Demon Souls is special
I find from software games really hard to rank because they all have strengths and weaknesses that the others don't but
Nothing from dark souls to sekito beats demon souls in terms of atmosphere and ambience in my opinion
I mean just listen to this clip
That's right atmosphere in five seconds of latria is thicker than in the entirety of aerosol dungeon
The rattling of bars the screams of the prisoners the piercing chime of those mind flayer bells
It's legitimately chilling and depressive when you go through here
And what makes it genius is that this is a feeling that is reinforced by the gameplay itself
This is one of the few areas in souls that still intimidates me, even though I've played through it tens of times by now
There's this gameplay loop in this section
Which has you peering in to cells for loot and to avoid enemies?
yet the real goal of this Pettitt 'iv horizontal process is
To dull your awareness of the occasional vertical deathtrap that's lurking in the shadows
Furthermore every damn corridor looks the same and the keys are placed so far from the doors that they unlock that it forces you to
Retrace your steps and double back a process that masks your sense of progression through this place
so even though you're outside of these cells you feel like a prisoner and
There's no sound more terrifying to a prisoner than this aggravated warning bell of the mind flayers
it's an enemy that can easily one-shot even the most accomplished player to be honest if you let down your guard and
Pretty much every area in Demon Souls has this much character?
Enemies sound effects level design gameplay
They're all there and they all make the worlds feel lived in and distinct. There's boletaria castle with this theme of
Archers who attack you at range at the same time soldiers attack you in melee they're coordinated by contrast
There's the stone Fang tunnels with these resilient miners who can be dangerous
But who usually barely pay you in tenshun?
They're just in the background focusing on their work instead. And if you accidentally aggro them then it's pretty rough
There's the shrine of storms which has this visual aesthetic to it. That's actually never been
replicated in subsequent games
It's this level that makes you sort of fear the open sky and it forces you to listen to noises coming from the sky
So that you can avoid javelins coming your way and then there's the next level of latria
Which is one of my favorites it has you standing and fighting on these narrow platforms
against these gargoyles that are seeing you and
all the while you're fighting to the beat of this enormous heart that
Looms over you the entire time and who can forget Oh JEE Blighttown as opposed to other swamp areas
It's even broader with no real landmarks in it
the rain is pouring down so hard you can barely see and
Later on, you get to these hovels where the flies are
so thick in the air that you actually kind of do feel bad for invading this place and
The cool thing about these levels is that you can play them in virtually any order which is a design decision
I think helped the devs fully realize their vision for these areas because they didn't have to design them so that they
Blend in to one another, you know
Additionally being able to access most of the game from the get-go
Vastly expands the character builds that you can go for so to build this sorcerer built
for example
I went to one of the most difficult sections of the shrine of storms and
defeated the skeletons with my bare fists because that uses blunt damage and
Then I got this powerful curved blade which in turn allowed me to tackle different sections of the game
Like latria where I could quickly unlock Soul ray, which is this piercing
Powerful main spell that can carry you the rest of the game basically
Actually, I feel like the magic and Demon Souls was really ahead of its successes in many ways. Yes, it's very overpowered
but man
I'd actually prefer that to how weak and onions but magic kind of fields in the sequel's
Manner can regenerate over time here
and also when you use
consumables which feels more natural in my opinion
Plus Demon Souls magic can be cast really quickly and many spells can be used while you're moving
So this led to really fast-paced PvP alas the servers have been taken offline now
Which is another reason a remaster would go down really well
I particularly enjoyed how magic switched up my experiences with a lot of the bosses
My fight with the armored spider became this long ranged battle of timing and boss fights that required stealth were made more interesting
Thanks to spells like cloak which hides your presence. I think the reason that magic interfaces
Well with Demon Souls bosses is because the bosses here are far more
Gimmicky than in the sequels and I absolutely don't mean that in a bad way
I just mean that the bosses here in this game have more overt strengths and weaknesses than in the sequels
Bosses in Dark Souls and Beyond largely come down to timing
reflexes and skill which don't get me wrong is still an amazing experience, but
Bosses and demon souls are more of a puzzle
They're difficult in the beginning and then easier when you figure out how to solve it
the end result of this is boss designs that are incredibly memorable and
they have a ton of character to them like the old hero who attacks you based on the sounds you make
Or the fools Idol who conjures mirror versions of herself or made in Australia who barely fights back at all
Relying instead on her brave knight to take you down instead
Every single boss is like this pretty much and I would rant and rave about every one of them
But I'd pray spoil your experiences
If you hadn't played the music in these fights is amazing too most of them include choirs
And they're really orchestral arrangements that do stand out from songs in subsequent titles
Everyone who gets addicted to souls games usually has a boss, but they struggled against for hours, right?
And I want to hear about what yours was in the comments back then mine was flame loca
He's one of the few bosses in Demon Souls that requires really straightforward mechanical skill to beat he's aggressive to the point
Where you can't abuse spam healing which is a problem in Demon Souls
And there's lava on the floor to watch out for and he powers up as the fight goes on
Making it so that if you get greedy at the end you get punished
I
Think I ended up having such a hard time back in the day that I ended up coming back to the game later and rolling
a new character with this
focus in mind to defeat flame Locker so I picked up a heavy flame resistant shield in the first level and I
Completely Specht into strength just so I could carry this huge shield and have a really easy time against the boss
demon souls in general has more RPG elements it has
exploitable damage types like flame damage and blunt damage seem to make more of a difference and
there are way more varied upgrade materials and also there's inventory management which
Some may like some may dislike
I think most people hate the fact that in Demon Souls a
Common occurrence is not being able to carry a loot on the ground and having to discard something
That's pretty frustrating and I think back then I also didn't know how world tendency worked
So I probably made my flame lurker fight way way harder
So for those of you who don't know demon souls have this insane death penalty mechanic, whereby
Enemies in a stage would become more dangerous and do more damage
Every time that you died in that level in human form
The only way around this was not to die or you could play in phantom form at 50% health
So that you wouldn't risk making your area harder if you did die
Which was a trade-off that most players were happy with because it stopped their difficulty
spiraling out of
The fact that they put this in is such a brave decision to put such a punishing mechanic in the first Souls game. No less
During its development
Demon Souls actually became known internally as a failed project until hid otaku Miyazaki took the reins
He went on to say this great quote. He said I figured if I could find a way to take control of the game
I could turn it into anything. I wanted best of all if my ideas failed nobody would care
It was already considered a failure
So this led to a lot of risks like world tendency being taken and while the game certainly wasn't a success at launch
there was this word-of-mouth effect that eventually spread of this deep punishing game from Japan and then
Namco Bandai and Atlas eventually decided to publish it in the West. I know I heard about it from word of mouth
I heard stories about this final boss that could drain the levels from you that you'd accumulated throughout the game and I thought
Damn, that sounds so metal
So what is the actual likelihood of a remaster?
Early this year there was this interview with Game Informer. Where Nia's Aki mentioned that a remaster was possible
but only if it was a studio that
Really loved the original work and really put their heart and soul into realizing it again
Then that's something I would enjoy he goes on to cite this discomfort with looking back on his previous works
But he says that I understand that there are many users and many players and fans out there who really loved demons
So if that's something they could accomplish with a studio that loved the work then yeah, I'd be okay with that
Of course this all relies on Sony too
he says you'd have to see what they are thinking about it and it seems like a no-brainer right as I feel like a
Remaster would offer something valuable to those looking to play it again
But then they could also engage millions of new players with this millions of people don't own a ps3
But they have started playing from software games in the past few years whether on PC or Xbox or even ps4
Considering that from software have a good relationship with Sony assumedly
blood-borne sold really well
and that the ps5 is looming in 2020 a
Remonster would pull the entire souls community into the PS 5 ecosystem similar to what they did with blood-borne
I thought about starting a petition for this and
While I'm convinced that there's this unbridled desire from software fans, that would make a petition successful
I don't know if I feel comfortable putting that kind of pressure on from software
Yet ask me again in a few years because I really can't imagine a remaster never being made
so for now
I hope that this video at least helps the 60% of you who haven't played demon souls
Kind of understand why it's a work of art and why it has such a cult following
- those of you who have played demon souls
please share something you'd loved about the game whether it's a location a boss or an experience down in the comments below or
Maybe use the hashtag des remaster on Twitter if you want to get trendy with it and to Sony
please
It's free real estate
Before I end this video I want to show off the Sennheiser PC 37 X. Is this really good budget headset
That's currently $30 off if you use the link in the description, and it's a product
I was already recommending to friends even before crop reached out to me
I used to use drop calm way back when it was still called mass drop and I always liked their
collaborations with big brands because they tend to clean up their designs and
Also offer a cheaper price on top of that this clean matte black headset is no exception
So first up it has an open back design
Which I personally prefer and use over closed back headphones open-back headphones prevent heat buildup
they afford a more natural sort of sound which is great for editing and
You can actually hear sounds that are around you while you're gaming or listening to music
Since I've been playing demon souls all week
There were moments in game in latria in particular
Where having good surround sound just saved my life being able to track enemies behind me
And also if you want to adjust that volume the headphones also come with a volume slider on the right ear cup
Which is something you'll come to swear by once you've gotten use to it
One thing that does usually bother me with headsets is that they often skimp out on the microphone quality
Because usually if you think about it, it's your friends hearing the microphone. Not the user so
Manufacturers often let it slide
however
One of the best selling points of these headphones is that the mic quality is way better than its competitors at this price point
Which as you can hear now has lots of body and a detail to it that is only enhanced by the inbuilt
Noise canceling the PC 37 X punches way above its weight for the price point
So check it out in the description below if you're in the market for this kind of thing
Thank you to drop for sponsoring me and letting me try my hand at being a tech youtuber
It was actually a lot of fun filming something completely different like this. So I appreciate the opportunity
But thank you for watching and I'll see you next time